GET VACCINATED DESPITE THE
DEADLY SURGE.
>> THE SPIKE IS A LITTLE
SHOCKING.
IT'S REALLY RAGING HERE.
>> EVERYBODY IS SCARED.
EVERYBODY IS COMING DOWN WITH
IT.
IT'S ALMOST LIKE A PLAGUE.
>> I HAVE BOTH SHOTS OF THE
VACCINE AND PEOPLE JUST ACTED
LIKE IT DOESN'T HELP.
IT BOTHERS ME SOMETIMES THAT
PEOPLE JUST ACT LIKE COVID IS A
BIG JOKE.
I ALWAYS WANT TO SAY WELL, WHY
DON'T YOU JUST COME RIGHT UP
HERE TO THE CEMETERY AND I'LL
SHOW YOU MY HUSBAND'S GAVE AND I
CAN SHOW YOU IT'S NO JOKE.
>> Reporter: OVER THE FIVE DAYS
WE SPENT IN CARTER COUNTY,
MISSOURI IT FELT LIKE COVID WAS
CLOSING IN AROUND US.
THE POSITIVITY RATE IS 32%.
SOME PEOPLE WE WANTED TO
INTERVIEW TOLD US THEY WERE JUST
EXPOSED OR TOO SICK TO TALK.
WE FIRST CAME IN OCTOBER 2020
WHEN COVID WAS STARTING TO SURGE
IN RURAL AMERICA.
WHEN WE HEARD ONE OF THE DINERS
WE INTERVIEWED PEOPLE IN CLOSED
FOR COVID, WE WANTED TO COME
BACK AND SEE WHAT HAD CHANGED.
BY THE END OF THE SPRING, MANY
THOUGHT COVID WAS OVER, BUT IN
THE PAST FEW WEEKS, IT'S RAGED
THROUGH TOWN.
THE VACCINATION RATE IS VERY LOW
WITH ONLY 27% FULLY VACCINATED.
>> THE OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF
OUR PATIENTS ADMITTED TO THE
HOSPITAL WITH CLINICALLY SEVERE
COVID ARE UNVACCINATED.
I DIDN'T REALIZE HOW
UNVACCINATED WE WERE, I GUESS,
THAT'S MY FAULT.
I DIDN'T CONTINUE TO PUSH AS
HARD AS I SHOULD HAVE TO GET
PEOPLE VACCINATED BECAUSE I
THOUGHT EVERYBODY WAS BECAUSE
THE VIRUS AND DISEASE WAS
ABATING BUT I WAS WRONG.
IT CAME BACK LIKE A BRUSH FIRE.
ARE YOU VACCINATED?
>> NO, BUT IT WILL BE.
I WAS SKEPTICAL OF IT UNTIL I
WATCHED ALL THIS HAPPEN.
>> Reporter: JIM'S WIFE RUTH
FOUGHT CANCER FOR 12 YEARS BUT
COVID KILLED HER IN EIGHT DAYS.
HE SAYS THE DOCTOR TOLD HER NOT
TO TAKE THE VACCINE BECAUSE OF
HER CHEMO.
WHEN DID YOUR WIFE DIE?
>> JULY THE 20th.
I TALKED TO HER UP UNTIL SUNDAY
WHEN SHE DIED AND SHE SAID THIS
IS BAD.
SHE SAID YOU-ALL NEED THE SHOT.
I THINK SHE RIGHT.
>> Reporter: LAST TIME WE CAME
HERE THE DEBATE WAS OVER MASKS
AND IT HAD GOTTEN VERY
POLITICAL.
>> WE SIT IN THE COFFEE SHOP AND
WATCH PEOPLE WALK IN THE DOOR
AND SEE A MASK AND SAY DEMOCRAT.
>> Reporter: LATER THAT FALL
THERE WAS A COVID SURGE IN THE
AREA BUT THE HEALTH CENTER SAYS
THIS WAVE IS MUCH WORSE.
AFTER JUST TWO DAYS OF SCHOOL
THIS AUGUST, ABOUT 20 KIDS
TESTED POSITIVE.
FIVE DAYS LATER, ALMOST A
QUARTER OF STUDENTS WERE UNDER
QUARANTINE.
THE PRESCHOOL HAD TO CLOSE FOR
TWO WEEKS.
PEOPLE IN TOWN WERE GOSSIPING
WHO HAD IT AND WHERE THEY GOT IT
AND THEY'D ALL SEEN OUR LAST
STORY.
>>.
LAST STORY YOU DID, I KIND OF
THOUGHT IT WAS ALL BULL MYSELF.
>> Reporter: TELL ME WHY?
>> THAT'S THE WAY PEOPLE ARE
HERE.
I THINK PEOPLE HERE TRY TO TAKE
CARE OF EACH OTHER.
THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT TO TALK
ABOUT AND TALK ABOUT COVID.
THEY NEED TO WALK THROUGH THE
COVID WARD.
THAT WILL CHANGE YOUR MIND.
>> Reporter: JIM ADMITS SOME
PEOPLE ARE PRETTY SET IN THEIR
VIEWS.
>> A GOOD FRIEND OF MINE, HE
HASN'T HAD THE SHOT BUT
EVERYWHERE HE GOES, IF HE GOES
ANYPLACE, HE WEARS A MASK AND
HE'S PROBABLY ONE OF THE BEST
GUYS I KNOW, BUT YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO CHANGE ANYTHING ABOUT
HIM.
MAYBE YOU OUGHT TO INTERVIEW
>> Reporter: WOULD HE TALK TO
US?
>> YEAH, BUT YOU PROBABLY
WOULDN'T LIKE WHAT HE WOULD TELL
YOU.
>> Reporter: THAT'S OKAY.
>> LET ME GET MY PHONE.
>> HELLO?
>> HEY, I'M SURROUNDED.
I NEED YOU TO COME DOWN HERE.
I'M SERIOUS.
>> WHAT ARE YOU SURROUNDED BY?
>> A BUNCH OF WOMEN.
>> OKAY.
I'LL BE RIGHT THERE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
HEY, THEY'RE GOING TO INTERVIEW
YOU.
>> OH, NO, THEY AIN'T.
>> YEAH, YEAH, COME ON.
>> CAN I SIT DOWN THERE BY YOU?
>> Reporter: WHY DO YOU NOT WANT
THE VACCINE?
>> I AIN'T TAKING THAT SHIT.
AIN'T TAKING IT.
I DON'T LIKE PEOPLE TRYING TO
PUSH A SHOT ON ME OR SOMETHING
ELSE BECAUSE I'M AS BULL HEADED
A FELLOW AS YOU'VE SEEN.
>> Reporter: LAST FALL COVID PUT
HIM IN THE HOSPITAL FOR SEVEN
DAYS.
>> I WAS ON EVERYTHING THEY HAD.
STEROIDS, FULL DRIP, PLASMA FROM
PEOPLE THAT HAD COVID, DRUGS
THAT THEY GIVE MY PRESIDENT
TRUMP AND THEY FINALLY BURNED IT
OUT OF ME.
>> Reporter: WHAT'S THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE VACCINE
AND THE DRUGS YOU TOOK LIKE
REGENERON?
>> WELL, I WOULD HAVE TOOK
ANYTHING.
I WOULDN'T HAVE MATTERED WHAT IT
WAS.
>> Reporter: BUT WHY WOULD YOU
TRUST REGENERON AND NOT THE
VACCINE?
>> AM I GOING TO HAVE TO --
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> I DON'T KNOW.
>> WELL, THE ONE THING IS THEY
SHAFTED MY PRESIDENT.
THEY WOULD HAVE HAD THE VACCINE,
ALREADY HAD IT ALREADY HAD IT
BUT THEY WOULDN'T GIVE IT TO HIM
BECAUSE THEY KNOW HE WOULD BE
REELECTED SO THEY HAD TO SWINDLE
AROUND AND SCALE AROUND AND KEEP
IT FROM HIM JUST AS SOON AS THE
ELECTION WAS OVER AND HE GOT IT.
I AIN'T TAKING YOUR MEDICINE.
I'LL TAKE WHAT THEY GIVE HIM BUT
I'M NOT TAKING YOURS.
>> Reporter: HE TOOK THE
VACCINE, THOUGH.
>> HE MIGHT HAVE.
I DON'T KNOW THAT.
>> I THINK THEY GIVE HIM THE
REGENERON.
>> Reporter: THEY DID GIVE HIM
THAT BUT HE DID TAKE THE
VACCINE.
>> LATER ON PROBABLY, YEAH.
I'M NOT SAYING HE DIDN'T.
I DON'T KNOW THAT.
THAT'S WHAT PISSED ME OFF AND
I'M NOT TAKING IT BECAUSE I'M
THAT BULL HEADED.
♪
>> Reporter: THERE IS NO
EVIDENCE FOR WHALEN'S THEORY BUT
HE WASN'T ALONE IN HIS
SKEPTICISM.
HAVE YOU THOUGHT ABOUT GETTING
YOUR VACCINE?
>> NO WAY.
>> Reporter: HOW COME?
>> I DON'T WANT TO GET SICK.
>> Reporter: YOU THINK THE
VACCINE WOULD MAKE YOU MORE
SICK?
>> PROBABLY.
IT MADE MY MOM SICK.
>> Reporter: OKAY.
YOU MEAN WHEN SHE GOT THE --
>> WELL, SHE GOT THE VACCINE IN
FEBRUARY.
>> Reporter: AND SHE GOT SICK ON
MONDAY WITH COVID -- MAYBE
COVID?
>> YEAH.
>> Reporter: IS HE GOING TO GET
TESTED?
>> PROBABLY NOT.
SHE'S STAYING HOME AND I'M
BRINGING HER GROCERIES AND DOING
WHATEVER I CAN AWAY FROM HER.
>> Reporter: YEAH.
>> ONE OF HER FRIENDS TESTED
POSITIVE AND SHE HAD BEEN WITH
HIM SO MORE THAN LIKELY.
>> I'M BEHIND RIGHT NOW BECAUSE
I WAS DOWN FOR ABOUT A WEEK AND
A HALF BEING SICK AND I DON'T
CARE.
I GOT IT.
I TOLD EVERYBODY, HEY, I HAD
COVID.
IF YOU DON'T WANT TO GET AROUND
ME, DON'T GET AROUND ME.
I HAVE IT.
>> Reporter: DID YOU HAVE THE
VACCINE?
>> NO.
>> Reporter: WHY NOT?
>> THERE IS NOT ENOUGH RESEARCH
ON IT.
I'M NOT TOTALLY AGAINST IT.
IF I HAVE TO TAKE IT AND IT WILL
HELP ME IN THE FUTURE AND NOT
HURT ME, YEAH, I MAY TAKE IT.
>> Reporter: ARE YOU VACCINATED?
>> I AM NOT.
>> Reporter: WHY NOT?
>> I JUST HAVEN'T GOT
VACCINATED.
>> Reporter: OKAY.
>> HAD A LOT OF PEOPLE AROUND ME
HAD IT.
I JUST HAVEN'T NEVER GOT
VACCINATED.
AROUND HERE, WE'RE PRETTY
COUNTRY FOLK AND IT'S HARD TO
GET PEOPLE TO DO SOMETHING THEY
DON'T UNDERSTAND COMPLETELY OR
THEY DON'T FEEL THE NEED TO.
>> Reporter: BUT ARE YOU IN THAT
CATEGORY?
>> WELL, I GUESS.
I DON'T REALLY GET DEEP WITH YA
BUT I BELIEVE IF THE GOOD LORD
WANTS ME RIGHT NOW, IT DOESN'T
MATTER IF I TAKE A VACCINE OR I
DON'T.
I KNOW A LOT OF PEOPLE SAY WELL,
HE GAVE YOU COMMON SENSE AND YOU
OUGHT TO GO GET THE SHOT, BUT
LET'S JUST, YOU KNOW, JUST THE
WAY I LOOK AT THINGS.
>> I DON'T WANT TO EVER GIVE
ANYBODY AN EXCUSE FOR DOING
SOMETHING LIKE NOT GETTING
VACCINATED, BUT THE REASONS DO
HARKEN TO SOMEONE WHO HAS, YOU
KNOW, BEEN TOLD THEY'RE A DUMB
HILL BILLY ALL THEIR LIFE BY THE
REST OF THE COUNTRY.
THAT IS NOT AN EXCUSE BUT PART
OF THE REASON.
I DON'T KNOW THAT WE'RE
OPPRESSED OR DISENFRANCHISED, I
DON'T KNOW IF WE DESERVE TO FEEL
THAT WAY HERE BUT WE'RE A
FLYOVER STATE.
IN A SOCIAL SITUATION WHERE PEER
PRESSURE IS SO HARD, WE'VE HAD A
LOT OF TROUBLE TO TRY TO GET
PEOPLE VACCINATED.
TO BREAK OUT OF THAT PEER GROUP
IS VERY HARD FOR PEOPLE.
>> Reporter: HAS ANYONE WANTED
TO GET VACCINATED IN SECRET?
>> WELL, YEAH.
ABSOLUTELY.
>> Reporter: TELL ME WHAT THEY
SAY?
>> WHEN THEY'RE IN MY OFFICE AND
SAY I DON'T WANT TO GET
VACCINATED AND THIS IS WHY.
IT USUALLY AT THE VERY BEST A
FALLACIOUS REASON, WE HAVE SET
UP THINGS WHERE WE CAN SNEAK ONE
IN YOUR ARM WHEREVER YOU NEED TO
DO IT BECAUSE THAT'S OUR GOAL.
>> Reporter: IT'S HARD BUT NOT
IMPOSSIBLE.
MORE PEOPLE GOT THE VACCINE
AFTER TWO LOCAL KIDS IN THEIR
20s WERE HOSPITALIZED WITH COVID
EARLIER THIS SUMMER.
LAST YEAR, WE TALKED TO BRIAN
WHO WAS PRETTY CAVALIER ABOUT
COVID.
>> I GUESS IF I GET IT AND IT
KILLS ME, IT'S SLOW WALKING
INSIDE SINGING FOR THE FAMILY.
>> Reporter: WHAT WOULD YOU PUT
ON YOUR TOME STONE?
>> DIDN'T WEAR A MASK.
>> Reporter: IT TOOK CONVINING
BUT HE AGREED TO TALK TO US
AGAIN AND TELL US WHAT HAPPENED
SINCE.
>> NO ONE FEELS LIKE THEY CAN
TRUST THE GOVERNMENT.
IT NOT MY FAULT NOBODY IS
WEARING THEIR MASK.
IT'S NOT MY FAULT NOBODY IS
TAKING THE VACCINE.
IT'S THE GOVERNMENT'S FAULT.
>> Reporter: DID YOU GET YOUR
VACCINE?
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> Reporter: DID YOU GET THE
VACCINE?
>> DOESN'T MATTER WHETHER I GOT
THE VACCINE OR NOT.
CORONAVIRUS DOESN'T CARE WHO YOU
ARE.
>> Reporter: I KNOW.
>> WHETHER YOU THINK YOU'RE A
BIG TOUGH GUY OR WHETHER YOU'RE
ANYTHING.
I DOESN'T MATTER.
IF YOU GET IT, IT CAN KILL YOU.
I DON'T WANT MY WIFE TO HAVE TO
WONDER WHEN THEY PUT YOU IN A
MEDICAL INDUCED COMA AND STICK A
TUBE DOWN YOUR THROAT IS HE
GOING TO COME BACK OUT OF THAT?
THAT'S WHY I GOT